good morning John I'm about to sing you
a song but first I have a couple of
things to tell you first my hands are
kind of permanently read and you'll find
out why later
second mostly I want to say thank you to
everyone who helped me out with this
there are a lot of different parts in
this song but I can't play any of them
so I had nerdfighters do it for me so
thank you to Paige sterling Danielle
Alicia Morgan and Kevin for all of your
amazing Irish fiddling and Benny whistle
playing I'm sorry I couldn't use
everybody's there are some problems with
sound and we're actually getting the
video to work in my computer so I just
use what I could use thank you to all of
you you did an amazing job
lastly before I share this song I want
to talk a little bit about squirrel
linguistics you may or may not know this
but squirrels they speak little squirrel
noises but in addition the way that we
have like eyebrow movements and like
facial expressions they have tail
movements and the tail movements are
extremely important in squirrel talking
and squirrels though you may not know
this have names and each name consists
of the vocal component and the tail
movement and this song is about a
squirrel named scuzzy kazoos all curl
[Music]
well there's a lot two ways to die under
Ireland skies but the worst way bar
might be a bit of a surprise that could
be night in a bar or hit by a car than
to be mahi and looking into her eyes and
hear the cries a fight demise my last
goodbyes
this will cease a 6-ounce ball a black
muscle it fire and she's the evil
mistake and the Serenity world man you
better start runnin heavy a mercy harsh
Scully cos it'll curl the homicidal
squirrel oh it was that the county
parrot scuzzy kazoos was there
slicing through the crowd like the mower
mowing lawns I watched the people fall
to her razor circles and she was right
there in my face before I know what's
goin on I risk my arm and tried to run
but I was star well she's a 6-ounce ball
on that muscle and her teeth a evil
snake and the Surete a world that ya
better start cuttin
have you ever see her she's cussing his
Ozel curl the homicidal squirrel our
teeth sink to my Armand everything but
pain was gone
what done it her blood-stained fangs she
looked into my eyes the fear was
paralyzed I felt the blood running from
my veins and the pain and oh the pain
and oh the pain
we'll see the six ounce ball of La
Salette fire and she's the eve of a
spanked and the Suren new world that you
better start for London have you ever
seen horror she scuzzy kazusa curl the
homicidal squirrel I'm only alive today
by all grace the only man who's been
with her and lived to tell the tale but
I keep my eyes wide so now her be denied
until the day and I still me right there
off my tail or Hillandale the rain and
hail she will prevail
we'll see the six outs for ma she's the
evilest thing in this is her any world
and Nevada stuntmen have Jana see our
stomach Azusa curl homicidal world
scuttling enthuse a girl homicidal world
Scottie kazusa curl the homicidal
squirrel John Oh what is that